White House sources tell CBS News they
suspect that Admiral Ronnie Jackson will
withdraw his nomination to be VA
secretary within days Senate Democrats
released new allegations of professional
misconduct so far unproven that
threatened to derail the president's
efforts to promote the chief white house
doctor
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest on this story major good
morning good morning yesterday Jackson
shared with his White House colleagues a
growing sense of fatigue with this
political fight and frustration that
allegations he contends are not only
unverified but untrue have come to
jeopardize his nomination now for the
time being Jackson still wants a chance
to tell his side of the story but unless
there is a sea change in the Senate the
expectation here is that Jackson is very
likely to withdraw he's won great a
seemingly optimistic dr. Ronnie Jackson
left the Capitol late Wednesday after
making his case to Senate Republicans
Democrats like Connecticut's Richard
Blumenthal said the tide had turned I
see no realistic path forward the White
House argued that four separate
background checks revealed no red flags
all of those nothing and came back with
a clean and recommended clean
recommendation but a document released
by Veterans Affairs Committee Democrats
contain damaging yet unverified
allegations including charges Jackson
created a hostile work environment
accusations of excessive drinking
including one instance where he wrecked
a government vehicle which Jackson
denied another charge improperly
dispensing medication such as the sleep
aid ambien and the opioid painkiller
percocet ranking committee Democrat John
tester said that practiced earned
Jackson the nickname Candyman by White
House staff none of those things have
come up in White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders said they had no knowledge
of these allegations until after Jackson
was nominated is it the position of the
administration that the people who have
raised these allegations are line
that's not what I said I said we've done
and multiple background checks have
taken place and we're continuing to look
at the situation these allegations led
Veterans Committee Chairman Johnny
Isakson to postpone Jackson's
confirmation hearings the White House
persuaded Isakson to move forward after
a week-long Senate recess so I'm gonna
do is make sure we have an open fair
hearing Whitehouse legislative director
Mark short they want to make sure that
they look at latest allegations that
came forward but we we think that dr.
Jackson is a is a great American patriot
worth remembering Jackson's nomination
was never a sure thing his closeness to
President Trump and lack of management
experience left many Senate Republicans
indifferent to his confirmation add to
that simmering Republican frustration
with White House vetting issues and Gail
you have a situation where Jackson may
pay the price it's looking that way dr.
Jackson not the only one under the
microscope for some ethics issues EPA
Administrator major Scott Pruett also
has some splaining to do on Capitol Hill
what do you expect from his testimony
today well Gail an internal document
that CBS has obtained shows that Pruitt
will tell Congress that others within
the EPA they're close advisors of his or
senior career EPA staff are to blame for
issues that are brought unfavorable
criticism to the EPA and Pruitt himself
and scrutiny from Congress the document
will say that Pruitt did not abuse
taxpayer dollars by breaking government
travel rules he will say he now flies
coach instead of first class and that
other EPA officials were to blame for
approving substantial pay raises to to
senior prude aides both of whom worked
for Pruitt previously in Oklahoma and
about that $43,000 private secured phone
booth that Pruitt had installed
he will also blame career staff at the
EPA all of this will come amid
bipartisan calls for Pruitt to resign
the White House has only said it's
reviewing all these allegations and
we'll decide Pruitt's fate after he
testifies before Congress yeah all right
major thank you very much me a very
interesting day for mr. Pruitt thanks a
lot you know it's interesting I can
remember the time when a president had a
sign on his desk that said the buck
stops here where people take
responsibility for their actions he also
has something to answer which as he said
he never
met with a lobbyist that had business
before the EPA whose wife was renting
him an apartment on favorable terms as
we reported this week the meaning did
took place the lobbyist did have
business before the EPA lots more to
discuss on capital home